what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into the death of
the Mighty Thor and this is an amazing
story I mean this is the end of Jane
Foster right like we've talked about
this before anybody who read Jason
Aaron's Thor god of thunder knew that
Jane Foster was gonna go away she was
never gonna stay for permanently we saw
that at the end of the story like we saw
that at the end of Thor got a thunder
that liked Odin's son gets the hammer
back eventually and Jane Foster was only
ever a temporary thing why people
freaked out about her becoming Thor I'm
not really sure I assume it's because
they didn't read that story so they
didn't know which is fine but
nonetheless this basically deals with
the return of a villain called mangog
now I want to talk about mangog for a
second because this guy is a beast he is
an absolute hast but it's kind of funny
because he was initially designed to be
a one-off in Marvel Comics he originally
appeared in Thor issues 154 through 137
by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby and the whole
idea of introducing man-god was to
basically say like over the course of
Asgard's history Odin had done some
pretty seedy things now for the most
part Odin had been depicted as a guy who
had like a nefarious past we didn't know
a whole lot about it it was one of those
guys where he just kind of did whatever
he felt needed to be done but in this
three-part story he was basically
revealed to us that somewhere along the
line Odin had essentially like destroyed
a race of beings and that this race of
beings had kind of poured their hatred
and their animosity into a singular
being and that arose in the form of man
God now this was very very like
cloak-and-dagger there wasn't a whole
lot of explanation offer there and so
over the course of that story by the
time issue number 157 came around what
ended up happening is the beings that
were destroyed by a by Odin have been
returned to the physical form and
because of that their animosity and
hatred had no reason to exist and so the
result was that mangog basically went
away now and Thor issues God issue 195 I
think I want to say was in 1972 it was
written by Gerry Conway and what URI
Conway did was actually bring man God
back and that's one of the big issues is
because technically there was no reason
for him to be alive when it comes to the
character of man God usually this means
that like everybody's gonna get rekt now
the only real exception of this came in
Walt Simonson's run of of the Mighty
Thor I guess of Thor when you ended up
having man gog who is basically beaten
by thor and technically that shouldn't
have really happened either it should
have been a standstill or man god should
have won the problem with this is that
man god's desire is to destroy Asgard
and so if he had won
Asgard would have been obliterated so it
was one of those things were like man
God kind of had to lose but the whole
Walt Simonson run of Thor was really
designed for the purpose of like taking
what Jack Kirby originally did in tales
of Asgard rolling that into the main
Thor stories and then just kind of
rebuilding the entirety of the Asgardian
mythos especially because of the fact
that Thor had been struggling for a few
years between the time that Jack Kirby
and Stan Lee stopped riding him and the
time that Walt Simonson picked it up so
the fact remains here what this does is
this initially picks up with man GOG
facing off against war Thor now again we
did that whole story arc with war Thor
basically this is Volk stag wheeling the
hammer of ultimate Thor and really what
happens here is like man God rolls right
through him man GOG just keeps coming
and coming one step after another and no
matter what war Thor does he can't win
there's no conceivable way he can defeat
this guy and so what ends up happening
is you end up heavy man God who
basically seizes the hammer of war Thor
and then just crushes it with his bare
hands that's the power of man GOG is
this just all this hatred and all this
vitriol coalesced into a singular being
given physical form and so it's
absolutely insane in terms of all the
power that he possesses the following
this battle we pick up with Jane Foster
who's just kind of arm wrestling
Hercules you know and it's kind of funny
because Hercules is like hey like you
know whenever you're not fighting
against villains or something like that
like if you want to get together you
know and like knock some boots you know
I'm down which is amazing but it's
basically a Odin son showing up to Jane
Foster and saying you need to come with
me because war four has been absolutely
wrecked and something's amiss here like
there is a being out there who just
totally decimated worth work and we have
to find out who this is
now of course what ended up happening to
you is Volk stag himself had just kind
of basically said like man GOG is coming
and this is when like Odin's son
basically reveals to Jane Foster like
man GOG is on his way and if man GOG is
on his way we're all basically doomed
because it's heard everything I had to
go toe-to-toe with him and I don't know
if you can handle this which is true
like no one knows if Jane Foster would
be able to hold her own against someone
like man [ __ ] but in this scenario like
he basically says look like you can do
what you can hold off as best you can at
the end of the day this may be a battle
that you will lose that you will not
survive and so what ends up happening is
she travels to Asgard to basically
beseech Odin I remember in terms of like
the whole war of realms which is still
going on that's been the whole ongoing
idea of like Jason Aaron's run on Thor
everything else has been a secondary
plot but
most part the nine realms are in chaos
they're in turmoil this whole war is
going on and like Odin is almost nowhere
to be found he's just sitting inside his
throne room standing next to Freya and
that's really about it and so Jane
Foster's showing up this is what so cool
Jane Foster shows up as just her self
cancer-ridden Jane Foster no more
capable of defeating Odin than just any
normal human being out there but she
basically shows up and says like either
you can sit in there and be a coward or
you can come out here and you can issue
the order to recall all the Asgardians
from across the nine realms and tell
them like they have to return here
because we have to face mangog we have
to face them together and it's not
really one of those things like if we
all hold hands we'll win it's one of
those things like if we're not all here
we're all going to die the other thing
here is that cold war son the brother of
Thor is basically like like a Stewart
more or less of the throne of Asgard
while Odin is kind of out there and
really cold war son is completely
ill-equipped to be the one to run the
show he's not incompetent right like
he's not a goof the issue with this is
that he doesn't really have the wisdom
of Odin so there are times when like he
should stand down and he doesn't in this
instance he should recall all the forces
of Asgard but he's not he's kind of
saying strong and saying look we'll do
our own thing you know we've got this
sorted out Odin basically makes his
appearance he shows up and says look I
will not stand for anyone calling me a
coward like I will not stand for anyone
being out here telling me that I've
somehow failed that I'm somehow derelict
in my duties like I am Odin
I run Asgard I was running Asgard before
you were born I will run Asgard after
you are dead I have seen more than you
could possibly imagine
I faced off against Celestials I've done
all kinds of different things I've went
toe-to-toe against Galactus you are just
a chick who showed up on the moon one
day got lucky and picked up the hammer
get out of here that's Odin's entire
response to this whole thing and it's so
cool because I'd be curious to ask Jason
Aaron why he didn't take things in this
direction Odin could just obliterate
Jane Foster especially in her current
form I would wager the reason he doesn't
do that is because of the fact that Thor
was with Jane Foster for quite some time
and even though they're not together
anymore there's still a lot of
connection between the two of them even
if they're only the closest of friends
and so it's a kill Jane Foster would be
to alienate his son potentially start a
civil war in Asgard proper and Odin
would be forced to either choose aside
let the war commence as where we'll just
kind of be obliterated so there would be
consequences to that particular act but
what we end up having is Freya who
basically comes to simply steps out and
says like Jane Foster's right we
to do something if we do not marshal our
forces we're all going to die and so
what we do is we switch to heimdal who
of course is at the Rainbow Bridge
watching like he always does and then in
comes man gog having made his way to
Asgard on to the Rainbow Bridge and like
literally begins this onslaught and
that's something that I want you guys to
notice here this is not like an even
battle right it's not like Heimdall's
holding his own and he's holding off and
doing the best he can I mean this is
like he's wrecked like that there's no
conflict here he's bitten in half the
Rainbow Bridge is totally destroyed
that's the power of man got the other
half of this is Jane Foster's
chemotherapy that's how Jason Aaron put
a clock on Jane Foster switch Cleo he
said like she's gonna die the Jane
Foster has cancer she has breast cancer
every time she changes into Thor it
washes away the chemotherapy and so
basically she starts back at square one
and so what this essentially means is
that it's the aquila of her having never
undergone chemotherapy in the first
place it shortens her life span and so
you have like dr. strange you have
various people who were here trying to
cure her in truth this is really just
like a stopgap or a hope is really all
it is
when Captain Marvel the original Captain
Marvel died in 1984 in the death of his
character by jim Starlin he died of
cancer so it is a foregone conclusion in
Marvel Comics that when a character gets
cancer they die there's no conceivable
way to get past that with Jane Foster
having undergone you know chemotherapy
multiple times what ends up happening
here is that she's essentially told if
you turn into Thor again you will die
like this is your last shot let the
chemotherapy happen let it run its
course because you're essentially this
is this whole scenario basically plays
out like this is the first time you're
basically undergoing chemotherapy and so
what is up happening is a hammer
basically appears and it's just got like
it it speaks to her says look like man
God is there you have to fight you have
to show up and that's the indication now
the other half of this is we switch to
Freya who basically takes control of the
destroyer armor now again this is one of
those huge moments to destroy your armor
is kind of like this huge creation that
was that was done really performed by
Odin it was originally designed to stop
the third host of the of the Celestials
I can never remember if it was the third
or the fourth but regardless of the
circumstances the destroy your armor
which created a combat the Celestials
but because of the fact that like man
God's showing up here and just taking
the full brunt of the power of the
destroy your armor there's nothing that
can be done it's one of these things
where it's like Thor has to respond
that's the power of me honor the
of the hammer this is something that I
also want you guys to notice Odin is
terrified and we never see that but it's
always been that way it's always been
the idea that like the man god is the
one thing that scares Odin more than
anybody else because one it's like all
this past sins come to haunt him and to
like there's no real conceivable way or
at least there shouldn't be any
conceivable way to stop man God and so
Odin being terrified for his life man
God taunting him the entire time I've
destroyed your destroy your armor I've
destroyed your Rainbow Bridge I've
destroyed everybody who's coming for me
I'm coming for you pops like I'm coming
for you old man and it's curtains the
Sun is setting on the Asgardian empire
that's just the way it is but the other
thing to keep him on here is like with
Thor and Odin son traveling back to
Asgard this is cool because it's him and
his father facing off against like man
doc but the reality of the situation is
they don't really expect to win instead
this is kind of like the whole scenario
with like Hyperion and Odin son facing
off against two beyonders at the
conclusion of Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers right like they knew they were
gonna lose it was one of those things of
like if we're gonna go out we're not
gonna go out sitting in chairs we're not
gonna go out and just let mangog destroy
us we're gonna go out in a blaze of
glory like if our legends survived then
like people will speak of the day that
Thor and Odin son fought to their last
breath against the man GOG and just like
fought with honor and died at the
bittern I mean that's that's that's I'm
sorry
you know fought and died and like you
know followeth fought at the bitter end
like that's gonna be the whole story
like that's what they're shooting for
because remember Asgard itself is very
much like rooted in the honor of combat
and so really like they don't expect to
win there's no real way for them to win
here and so what you end up having is
Jane Foster seizing control of the
hammer turning back into Thor and then
racing off to Asgard and business again
this basically means like Jane Foster is
going to die and so what you end up
having is her showing up and like
holding her own as best she can and
facing off against the man god and she's
able to she's able to do pretty well
just because the nature of the hammer
because the hammer is so powerful but in
reality again like this guy is supposed
to be unstoppable and Jason Aaron stays
true for the most part to the nature of
man god despite all the power that Jane
Foster has with this hammer at the end
of the day it doesn't really matter
because what she does is she basically
like ghosts or hurl mangog into the Sun
like the whole idea is just throw him
into the Sun call it a day let him just
like burn alive you know in this insane
amount of heat but man gog manages to
kind of ricochet his way around
then basically come back and when he
does like he just starts wrecking Jane
Foster again like he just starts tearing
her apart alongside like Odin son and
alongside like Odin himself it really
does seem to be the end and so what
happens is Jane Foster basically wraps
the man GOG in chains and then like
throw the hammer into the Sun with man
God in tow and so instead of him just
kind of ricocheting around like he did
before he actually flies into the Sun
directly but like everyone like like
Odin and Odin Sun and Freya everyone's
screaming at Jane Foster not to do this
because if they do it'll destroy the
hammer but at the end of the day like
she doesn't care the only thing that
matters to Jane Foster is destroying
mangog like preserving what's left of
Asgard and so were the hammer flies into
the Sun man God flies into the Sun and
both are seemingly destroyed at this
moment at this point right now there is
no more no more Mjolnir the hammer of
Thor is gone the man dogs destroyed
everything in Asgard is safe but Jane
Foster ultimately succumbs to her cancer
she essentially just dies I mean there's
there's nothing left for her there so
with that being said guys if you are new
here to come as explained make sure you
guys have the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
like I'm really curious cuz the
aftermath issue comes out and about a
mother probably about three weeks now
maybe two weeks because I think it's
stories about two weeks out ah but like
yeah so we'll get like the aftermath I'm
curious to see I mean the hammer will
come back people are probably gonna
freak out it's like no linear can't be
destroyed like yeah you're right it
can't be destroyed it will come back I
mean I don't imagine why it wouldn't
like it's definitely gonna make it
return how it makes this return I don't
know because there's no more ultimate
Thor hammer that hammer was crushed by
man got like beta ray bill still has
Stormbreaker but he's floating out there
somewhere I'm willing to surmise
whatever weapon Thor gets in the comics
will be the weapon he gets in infinity
war what was this gonna roll it over
that's exactly what's gonna happen
hey anyway guys uh yeah if you're new
here to come this explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]